who lay care podcast special guest got
my guy yo concrete in the building
what's goody kev welcome man so for
people who don't know
the last couple years you've been like
building a following on ig doing comedy
[ __ ]
yeah
but give me some of your background
before you decided to do the the
instagram comedy show because you've
been around for a minute like just kind
of in the scene of la and the music [ __ ]
so kind of break down some of your like
how you got kind of introduced into just
the entertainment world man i mean i'm
17 years in dog
you know sounds like 15 right djing
producing this [ __ ] type of [ __ ] you
know
and um like in uh 2000
i'm gonna say six or seven
uh i started really getting like a
little momentum with the music and i had
a record i'll call industry beefs you
were rapping mm-hmm okay yeah i was
producing wrapping my own [ __ ] at the
time you know
this is when like
having a studio at your crib was like a
big deal a big deal yeah you know
and uh i had a record called uh
how to industry beefs and that caught
the ear of uh steve labelle and shout
out to maniac maniac lobel yeah so mania
i mean echo bell and um uh and shauna
lewis
and this around the same time like i
remember when steve had me come over
this house right it was me sean
and steve the bell we were at his house
and he i'm sure jamie adler was hanging
around somewhere yeah he was somewhere i
mean crazy story jamie adams saw me
getting arrested
i got arrested at his [ __ ] uh at his
office right there in hollywood um
so we were at his house yeah you know
and he's like yo man i really you know
like i like your record and you know
thinking about you know hopefully you
know getting to manage you and he's like
yo
i have this other kid that i want to
show you and just let me know what you
think you know and we go into his garage
and he pops you know pops his record and
his there's this record called um the
bulletin got a bulletin got no name so
it was nip
at the time you know it's like nip was
barely like coming up you know yeah and
i remember me and him got signed the
same week to like you know you know to
get managed by the team
and that like that was the beginning of
more or less like me kind of getting my
feet with like in the industry you were
managing how long were you managed by a
lobel i was with him for like four years
oh wow mm-hmm that's crazy yeah yeah
it's like fan man that's great yeah yeah
you know so i got to you know get
records with a few of his other artists
like bone thugs and i ass
sean kingston yeah yeah yeah man
you know what i'm saying and then uh you
know my first record hit the radio was
called certified kush uh you know shout
out to dj fellaini fell on the whole
team um yeah like they they played that
at power mm-hmm yeah who's that was that
just you
yeah yeah yeah that was a solo record
called certified kush and then i had a
second record come out and you know that
one did like pretty well like i think we
did like 65 stations across the country
you know and that was that was called uh
uh we can make it rain and it was more
like a you know poppy industry record
you know i was i was i was really trying
to get in there on some like badges you
were going by concrete at the time nah
no i used to go as beretta what was it
beretta beretta oh [ __ ] i think i
remember yeah and this is how i know
like most of these dudes you know like
bash a lot of people see me doing skits
now with bash or frankie i've known
these guys these artists and it's like
dog i used to open up for these dudes
when i was like you know and like really
in the rap game
and then i went from you know my you
know unfortunately my my brother passed
away in 2008 he was like my hype man my
day-to-day manager everything kind of
deal you know and
passed away in 2008 and i decided to
just stop rapping during the time of
like the record starting to pop yeah so
you so you was
getting on the radio i was getting on
the radar trying to do shows i was
trying to travel and you know do my
thing
and uh your brother passed and that kind
of inspired you to just walk away from
doing music yeah i was like i'm done
with it you know because i just i just
started you know like you started seeing
like you know people start acting
different you know
and it was you know i i actually
credited like i'm glad if i if i would
have done blown up then you know i
probably would have just
i probably would have killed myself for
something because i wasn't in the right
state i was just i was just being uh you
know i mean imagine being 21 and then
like you have a record on the radio at a
time when having a record on the radio
deal was a big deal huge deal yeah back
then it was a big deal not so much now
yeah so it's like everywhere i went it
was like you know it was like people
already knew who i was and it was you
know people started acting different so
and you know things are being presented
to you who worked your record to radio
who was your like steve
steve st you guys
i mean i had a few people i mean i had a
few people working the record
uh one dude i'm not gonna mention his
name but uh you know we had leilani i
mean
i was just saying like is it like yeah
yeah i mean but we had like i mean like
like a ton of people were really [ __ ]
with the record so they were like yo man
i'm just dying to help out the situation
like 65 station that's what that is no
that's that's nice yeah that was cool
man so i would see the little bds or you
know reports and i was like okay cool
this shit's really happening and then
you know i'm retired and then i was like
that's it like from one day to another i
remember i i put out like one last music
video with me my wife uh nikki diaz and
you know we just did like one record and
then i ended up just you know doing a
video right here in silmar in my
neighborhood and that was it i was like
i'm out what happened when you told
steve you're gonna retire
oh they weren't happy
what are you doing yeah yeah nah man i
mean they weren't happy i mean you know
because like when i left them you know i
ended up doing like a collaboration with
uh um with uh gorilla black and his
brother hot dollar
so i was oh that's i was a hot dollar
yeah i was doing some stuff with them
called they were brothers dollar figures
i didn't know either wow i didn't know
either up until i started meeting them
really hanging around them
and then uh yeah man i mean you know i
got the call from steve i got the call
from like big you and it's like you know
what i'm saying and it was it was tough
man it was tough because i really wanted
to do music but it's just
i just it wasn't in my heart like to try
to talk you out of retiring
nah
i mean i i guess i mean it was
they just wanted to see where my head
was at you know
like sean and lewis kept in contact i
mean i talked to them still to this day
you know and recently they told me like
yo like why don't you do some music and
i'm like i don't know man i'm just yeah
i was gonna ask you like uh
so you retire from music that's oh wait
this is like 2009 2000 yeah 2008 kind of
bleeds into like 2010 but by by 2010 i'm
trying to hold like a bunch of odd jobs
yeah i was gonna say what do you do
like what like what's the next decade of
your life look like
because i feel like you just started to
get into the comedy thing recently right
yeah the next decade after that i was
literally just um i remember i got fired
from my last job i conned my way into
accounting job at uh fias paredes and
factory to you at the corporate office
my mom loves that store
arizona that i used to go to every
[ __ ] week with my mom she'd pick me
up from high school and we go to the
fias padera's place and get [ __ ]
for a dollar
[Laughter]
my mom loves the deal yeah
trust me i love that place so you know i
was worried you were on the corporate
side there was on the corporate side
somehow somewhere i got bamboo then a
little bit a little
fictitious lies on the
on my resume on the resume
about about about accounting
[Music]
you know and then uh i mean i was doing
really good man just collecting pennies
and just you know typing [ __ ] in and i
was i was doing good but the dude was
like man you're not happy he literally
called me to it's obviously like bro i'm
not your man i'm not happy
he sees it in my eyes and he's like bro
i'm just gonna give you your last check
and just man we'll see you later brother
wow i was like what he was like yeah man
just go do your music because he had
known that i was you know
i was like all right [ __ ] it so i went
home and i told my wife
i was like well she's my girlfriend at
time my uh a wife now but i was like
look with this money i'm gonna buy a
camera
i'ma buy a camera there's this youtube
[ __ ] right now
and people are just doing a bunch of
music videos yep at this time i already
had relationships in the industry more
or less and i was like look i'm going to
call them i'm going to tell them i'm
going to do the music videos for free
get it
and let's go
and that's exactly what i did like the
first dude to i think i did a music
video for was essay dazzling and my boy
any means
and then uh my boy is a dad i was like
for the third video i was like look man
don't pay me just buy me this lens
he's like pharrell's like yeah look
here's the amazon link dog buy that lens
i need that the lens he's like he'll
make a video look better and that lens
man i did like 200 music videos on that
[ __ ] lance dude so you were shooting
v so you became a video director i
became a videographer like in 2010 and
you're directing your editing as well
everything everything there was yeah i'm
right i went and bought like a little
mac a little imac computer and you know
and again this is a time where like
people having a a video on youtube was
was was crazy for sure for sure
different era different such a different
like there was no other comedy [ __ ]
really going on it was it was there was
no vloggers it was just straight either
you had a music video or some corporate
[ __ ] up there right you know or you were
a big artist and you know i mean even
big artists this is when at the time
when they were leaving like
terrestrial television like bt you know
yeah it's like like nobody was really
carrying them there was like black
diamonds was popping there was like yeah
that was yeah you know oh yeah for sure
black diamonds uh you know power of tan
yeah i mean i mean there was a bunch of
dudes that were you know you became just
a videographer for artists
over 200 videos
oh yeah like in the first two years oh
wow
so you were really
just cracking them up what was the
biggest video you you did was i mean
what's the biggest what i've done yeah
like that you've done that like as far
as views or song-wise like what's what's
i mean i i wouldn't even i wouldn't even
i would i can't even tell you because i
mean i don't know i mean as far as like
the biggest one that
i might have i don't know it could be
[ __ ] something with saigon
um
but i don't know i mean i got videos i
got millions of views with like trish
toledo like
you know i started doing
just like i got out of the hip-hop
situation i struck like i started doing
different genres you know so i got like
millions of views on like like a thought
[ __ ] i got millions of views on
straight like you know what people would
consider mexican rap i guess you know
that's big but like i guess all in all
my views i'm i'm probably i'm i'm
probably good at a billion a billion
views would you uh
[Music]
are you still doing any of that now yeah
so you're still doing that yeah i just
got back from miami last week with magic
i shot a music video with him and miami
oh man yeah so a lot of people don't see
it because i don't know so listen you do
all the music video [ __ ] keeps you kind
of in the in the um
in the industry in the industry right
and then at what point in time do you
realize that there's something with the
ig comedy [ __ ] because i that's more
recent so like yeah how'd you make that
you know i mean i've always been funnier
around my boys i've always [ __ ] around
and i've always done characters and i
was acting during during the 10 years
that i'm doing music videos you know i
went to auditions and booked a few gigs
you were doing something yeah for sure
like i was on wilfred with elijah wood i
you know i did a few movies um
uh you know so i was always acting but
it wasn't consistent enough for me to be
like yo i'm gonna just stay here and
hopefully i i make money he's like nah
man i got a wife i gotta you know i got
i got a kid i just can't you know
so you gotta pay bills yeah i do so i
kept the shooting i was like you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna chill on the
acting and doing all these [ __ ]
auditions because it was like even
though you're booking right
but you're booking one out of thirty so
you gotta go on a lot of times so you
gotta go on 60 auditions takes up a lot
of your bandwidth it does bro it's just
a lot of time and like you know like
you're spreading yourself out then with
that [ __ ]
um
so then uh so that i'm doing all that
and
you know it wasn't until 2000 i want to
say 18. i was shooting a music video for
my boy second in compton menace and we
were at the
on on fairfax right there by like where
big got killed at those uh those lights
yeah the miracle mile lights and it's
the last shot of the music video
you know we got all the gear in the
truck
we're like we're gonna park the truck
right here we're just gonna hit this
corner and go to the lights and shoot
the scene and get back in the car and
dip
maybe it took about 10 minutes 10 12
minutes but that's how we got back 40
thousand dollars worth of gear was gone
oh [ __ ] and this is all your gear get
gone
my boy said gone had to take off his
rolex put in the car and he was like i'm
gonna leave it in my bag i don't need it
for this shot
with like his ipad and he had like a
bunch of records written you know just
old you
know so we come back and everything is
gone dog car
everything i've worked for kev for the
last 10 years in that i mean that's a
lot of equipment
yeah bro lights lenses
laptops everything everything though i
took the whole [ __ ] kitchen that day
like all kinds of stands and [ __ ] right
someone stole the actual vehicle nah
they just they they when they did a
dumping like a grab and dump you know
just put into the car and boom
it was it was a ring that was happening
at that area so come to find out last
year come follow me out of the bank
crack my window yeah i took had 15 grand
cash on me see ran into a ups store to
get something notarized and within two
minutes of being in the store they
cracked my back window i had the i had
the money i left it in the car under my
seat of course and they took my bra i've
never had to commit murder in my life i
can only imagine how you felt oh dog
yeah i wanted to commit murder i was
calling all the homeland
i called everybody i knew i was like yo
like i don't even want the money back i
want my [ __ ] laptop back i put the
word out that's exactly what i did kev i
called everybody i knew in every hood i
was like yo put the word out and
especially in that hood i was like yo
dawg i know you guys know something man
you know i remember i did i did the most
vulnerable post on social media had ever
done
i hate when [ __ ] cry on social
media right and i'm there with like can
i even put that [ __ ] in black and white
so they can feel it more
and i'm like man if anybody knows
anything
so any idea who did it or did oh no yeah
i mean they ended up catching the guys
and [ __ ] did you get your [ __ ] back nah
nah there's like restitution but dude
i'm not even gonna see that back so i
don't expect it you know they caught the
guys but you never got your [ __ ] nah nah
nah i mean they had sold that [ __ ] by
the time that you know
like they weren't gonna wait on my [ __ ]
they were like this is the first [ __ ]
we're gonna get rid of you know
they they found a backpack right they
call me like at night like i'm [ __ ]
crying at home
they call me like at four o'clock in the
morning and [ __ ] and they're like we
found a backpack when we found a case
i was alright cool so i get over there
and the dude's like yeah it's a black
backpack i was like perfect it's mine it
has my laptop and my hard drives i had
just shot some music videos in
uh guatemala
oh no honduras and i had just shot some
music videos in honduras
and that footage was in there so i was
like
you know that was like twenty thousand
dollars so you had that that was in
there
so i get to the police shop and it's not
my [ __ ] backpack dog
it's not my backpack right
so i open the backpack and it has a
bunch of ids and credit cards
passports all kinds of [ __ ] i was like
well you guys might need this back he's
like oh [ __ ] we didn't even like go
through it i was like oh thanks man and
then they found the case one thing they
did find was a 20 000 panasonic monitor
for like you know for playback on on set
and i guess like it must have been too
heavy for them so they just dropped it
[ __ ] and uh the cops are like yo we
found this and i was like whoo 20 g's
here we go
took that home
that was it and yeah so yeah anyway
anyway so i do this post on social media
crying asking [ __ ] begging for people
to just give me anything
right
and you know
that was the most broken i had ever or
you know the most vulnerable and
transparent i have been on social media
up until this point all people know is
that i travel i shoot i'm here i'm there
i'm traveling everywhere type of [ __ ]
you know but nobody cares about that
[ __ ] right that pose got a lot of love
did you get a little gofundme popping
nah no no but my boy um uh you know my
boys from 27 junkies my cousin uh burst
rock and the whole team and they you
know jake has actually threw like a
little a fundraiser for me and i was
able to get like a few grand and you
don't get a laptop and [ __ ] like that
you know so you know shout outs to them
man so that was the team right there
that came through for me hey what up man
we got to interrupt the interview real
quick to tell you about our family at
odd socks now when i be riding for odd
socks so hard man it's because i really
love the product they got the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ] world i
got a pair of odd socks basics on right
now go get those they got the socks wwe
joints you know i'm saying shout out to
the undertaker pepsi [ __ ]
really whatever you need some weed socks
nickelodeon but really they got the
draws now ladies and gentlemen
i'm holding a pair of tapatio underwear
right now
you want some pop tarts on your dick pop
tart draws and these [ __ ] are
so comfortable
like
man so listen you gotta go to
oddssoxofficial.com
and use the uh promo code the discount
code bootleg kev
at oddssocksofficial.com you'll save 20
off underwear the most comfortable socks
in the world crazy licenses not only
they got the wwe they got the scarface
they got the street fighter they got the
nickelodeon they got it all so make sure
you hit that website oddsoxofficial.com
save 20 off with the promo code bootleg
kev all right go do that shout out to
odd socks let's get back to the
interview nothing like that people man
that's the oh man that's happened to me
twice i
it's terrible dog it's crazy because you
brought a baby bash we were in um lake
havasu in 2011
and baby bash was doing a radio
event for spring break and our room was
next to his room
and uh
somebody [ __ ] the maid somebody they
ran like like cleared out everyone's
rooms took my [ __ ] laptop on my hard
drive at the time i'm like making 30
grand a year doing radio in las vegas so
my macbook is like it's everything yeah
so i was sick to my stomach like there's
nothing like getting get to having
someone jack you for some [ __ ] that's
like
it ain't even about like i had pictures
of my kid on there i'd yeah you know it
was just so much yeah [ __ ] it
made me want to kill a [ __ ] oh
yeah dawg yeah that's how i feel dude
and you know like i'm already doing
comedy at this time dude like you know
i'm i'm behind the scenes writing comedy
for other dudes and writing skits for
other dudes and whatnot
and uh my boy was like you know what
dude like
you look like [ __ ] man you gotta do
something he's like nobody's gonna do
your comedy how you would do it khan so
why don't you just give it a shot and
see if it works out
and then i did one video man and i had
like i don't know 2 000 followers and
like overnight i went up to like 2 500
or something i was like okay i got 500
followers overnight with this [ __ ]
that's a big deal
you know i was like i just got a fourth
of the followers that i have overnight
all right and then i i remember like you
know because before i was like the only
people that commented like you know and
i'm that i'm doing cool [ __ ] like i'm in
i'm in you know jamaica with the marlies
i'm i'm in you know [ __ ] europe like
i'm doing cool [ __ ] but like you know
the only people that comment is just
like your mom and your cousin like hey
good [ __ ] man keep pushing right you
know what i'm saying like that's it you
know and for this [ __ ] it was like
people i didn't even know
i was like oh [ __ ] okay it wasn't just
followers and there were comments like
yo man funny [ __ ] i was like all right
cool and then the next day i did another
skit
and then that one went kind of that one
went kind of big it was me at a liquor
store where i'm seeing this this this
person get it was kind of like a
reaction video this person right now get
kicked out of the store and i'm reacting
to it
and that one when you know that one
again gave me like a thousand followers
overnight
like oh this should there's something to
this all right cool you know and then
yeah man from there just kind of
snowballed into like this [ __ ] thing
that it's like in two years man i've
been blessed to
get casual for movies now and you know
doing tv shows my tv show drops on
november on to be and wow
i got to be on my tv yeah man we just we
just uh you know won an award yesterday
for the elec um the panamanian easterly
film festival for like uh i think like
funniest comedy and you know funniest
comedy tv series so it's cool what's
your involvement with the with the tv
series i'm the star of it
yeah that's weird to say man that's
great are you like
any of the writing or any of the ideas
yeah yeah no of course but i think for
season two uh we just you know uh see uh
season one is wrapped and um uh for
season one yeah i mean obviously i mean
i had a lot of
i had a lot of involvement as far as
like improvising and rewriting some of
the stuff and
kind of you know
and unless you know second hand
directing a little bit you know but
definitely for the second season i i
will have a bigger part in it is the
second season already green lit
uh yeah fine oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we
are man i feel like there's need to be
more latino actors too i'm tired of
seeing carlos in every [ __ ] movie
or was his name heck you know the guy
who's in front of my guy noel noel but
he's like the guy he's like the go-to
guy in every movie it's like
it's like is there nobody else like yeah
i mean i just you know like i i guess
for me like it's always been difficult
to book those roles you know i don't
really have like a menacing facing [ __ ]
it's fair yeah he he fits the part yeah
so it's like you know like for me to
like like even when i booked the elijah
uh you know like on on um on wilfred you
know it was like this gangster dude i
love that show you know and i'm and i'm
robbing elijah wood in that [ __ ] and and
and my cousin like my cousin's watching
this [ __ ] he's a gangster he was like
dawg i would have slapped you for you
didn't even look scary and i was like
yeah all right good you know yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know i catch the
chest what's the name of the tv show
wilfred no no the tv show that oh ghetto
busters ghetto busters yeah yeah when's
the first season debut uh i believe
november 4th oh my god that's big man
toby's dope it's like a app like it's
like free tv yeah yeah there's free tv
man you just go in there and watch it
you have to have a subscription nothing
nothing just go up there and watch it
yeah it's a vibe man um so
what is kind of like since you've been
doing the ig comedy thing like obviously
there's a lot of quote-unquote ig
comedians
there's a bunch yeah
what has been kind of like your
secret into like kind of standing out
and
i don't follow trends
i don't follow the trendy tick tock of
the day i'm not doing squid games this
week um
you know i i technically go against the
grain on everything that happens you
know i mean if it's something that's
like i remember like i mean one of the
biggest kits i did was an r kelly skit
right you know
and that was around the time yeah that
was it was trendy but it just
you know
what you do a lot of people were making
like for example that skit i remember a
lot of people were playing gayle king's
part the interviewer
and i was like [ __ ] that man how funny
would it be to see the cameraman's point
of view
true
right so i ended up doing that and then
that [ __ ] got me like twenty thousand
followers overnight the cameraman
you know that's a great yeah so i played
the cameraman point of view because
everybody else was playing the gayle
king like the interviewer like they
wanted to put themselves in the moment
right i was like nah that's just that's
already a scene as it is let that happen
let me add the cameraman point of view
and then that's just it was off it was
out of here you know
um but yeah it's just you know like i
don't
you know social media comedy is really
like again man i i feel like it's comedy
is just like music subjective right
people like what they like yeah but i
just tend to go against the grain like i
don't like to follow the trends you know
and i like to be as original as possible
as original as possible you know what
i'm saying
um you know like even when i do my
characters like you know like when i did
it was so funny like recently somebody
was asking me like man how do you bridge
the gap between black and brown and
trying to you know the comedy and i was
like i'm not trying to bridge no gap
just doing you i'm just doing me you
know like when i did andre 3000
i wasn't thinking like i'm gonna do
andre 3000 because it's gonna get me
closer to the back of me i was like no
i that would just be a funny ass [ __ ]
andre thousand the mexican version like
that [ __ ] would be funny that should be
hilarious and dude and i had a bunch of
comments on my tick tock and on
instagram like loving it you know and
from the black community they're like
man see here's a comedian that didn't
have to do blackface none of that to
just be for sure yeah and i think you
know that to me means a lot you know
what i'm saying like i'm not doing
comedy for anybody specific i'm just
doing what i think is funny to me and if
you happen to be white black or asian or
mexican and you like it cool like you
find that tick-tock's a little bit
easier to get traction on than ig
because i feel like tick-tock i've seen
people go from like zero to like
like quick on tick-tock yeah they're
doing the right [ __ ] oh yeah i feel like
ig is a slower climb yeah i mean i mean
definitely ig's a slower climb now
because of the fact that you know these
algorithms are different and
you know
whatever i don't really pay attention to
that i came into i know i started my uh
my instagram or really like really
started pedaling on instagram two years
ago
and at the time dudes that were already
big in the social media were like dog
you're getting followers in a time where
it's hard to get followers no for sure
right
i just tricky i feel like tick tock like
you know as long as you just stay
consistent on tick tock yeah yeah you
know what i'm saying you'll be all right
but i mean but you got to stay
consistent and all your i mean i say
consistent on my facebook tick tock
how's how's your facebook cause face
people don't realize facebook
[ __ ] don't sleep i got millions
of views on facebook
people don't even realize it yeah
facebook is popping people just like be
forgetting that facebook's still a thing
but i'm like yo facebook especially for
like facebook stuff it's like like a
comedy [ __ ] like yeah facebook is
cracking dawg i i probably have the most
million views videos on there yeah
facebook is a is a movie you know that's
you know i mean that's the most i've
done but yeah man uh you and jay
valentino did a like a little tour
together mm-hmm uh
shout out to him too he's yeah shout out
to my boy jeff on two he's been killing
it for a while i remember when i first
met him i was like well we gotta put you
on the radio and then i don't know what
ended up happening i know he did like a
weekend with us like real but yeah
the station's tripping
he needs to be on the radio yeah that
being said um how'd that go
oh that was dope you guys were just kind
of pulling up to like it like i'm gonna
might look random as [ __ ]
dog it looks so it was super random dog
i mean you know like i was
you know it's like you you think you
popping yeah right and so i decided to
put this too i was like aj let's go on
this little like pull-up tour we'll just
do a bunch of meet and greets it should
be fine right so we do the flyer and we
get a really good response and [ __ ]
right
and like a week before two weeks before
we're leaving
i told you i was like aj check this out
dog i have a feeling that what if
it doesn't go as planned and nobody
shows up i was like it'd be great if we
just shot this [ __ ]
right
it'd be absolutely epic if we just shoot
the tour
and show what it is
yeah to be a comedian or to be somebody
trying to make it right
and that's exactly what happened uh we
had we good good turnouts we had really
bad turnout what was the worst place
the worst place uh uh albuquerque i
think
albuquerque thought we were hurting
phoenix tucson was lit uh you know el
paso was good um
dallas was cool houston was like houston
named his book like i ended up booking
some place
actually no uh i hate to say it but it
was odessa oh that's odessa was was bad
though that sounds like this interesting
i'll give you a tip because i didn't
even i didn't even
so this dude calls me like yo man we
want to bring you guys out to odessa and
i was like all right cool they're like
well where's that like oh it's a cell
phone spot you guys will be good i was
like bat cell phone spot we own can we
set up somewhere they're like yeah dog
so we get there
and we just i mean you know it's a tiny
little town dog yeah tiny little town so
you're
kind of driving by and all we see is a
[ __ ] cemetery
or like what the [ __ ] i was like dog and
i called the dude's like hey there's a
cemetery he's like yeah we're right at
the corner
so it was this little bit it was like
this is the whole cemetery and his store
was right at the corner by a cemetery
on the cemetery bro like there's flowers
and graves all around his shop
i asked him what the [ __ ] was going on
he was like yo
they went and bought all the houses in
the land here the city to put a cemetery
i'm the only one that didn't sell
what the [ __ ]
so we're sitting there so we're sitting
there bro like
you want us to do a meet and greet at a
cemetery bro like
you guys documented this everything is
documented man it was it's being it's
being added though we got it it's dude
the [ __ ] is really good though san
antonio was was
oh man are there any other uh creators
that that you [ __ ] with that are kind of
like in the latin comedy lane like
because there's a lot of there's a lot
of people doing their thing you know i
think like um my guy luciano knows best
from phoenix just yeah yeah i know who
he is
uh we just we just tapped in with the i
think they're called the mexican ways
mm-hmm yeah um i worked with them before
yeah there's like there i just feel like
there's like a is it's really popping
right now you know what i'm saying like
yeah outside of jay like who are some of
the other
people who you you want to collaborate
with are you or who you have worked with
i mean i think everybody that i've
wanted to collaborate i think i did you
know um and if i don't know them it's
probably because we just haven't came
across i haven't came across your page
or whatever the case but
i mean you know like man like for the
last two years and even until now for me
it's it's it's really been about like
showing proof for myself yeah you know
um
i kind of felt that i needed i need to
do my comedy right now i need to do what
i think is best for me and not
necessarily collaborate with someone
because
they got clowns
but because they're popping it's like i
i want to earn my seat at the table you
know and that's why i started doing
standard because there's a certain
stigma about oh if you're a ig community
stand-up you can't do stand-up or you
like you don't deserve a seat you know
i'm like at this time stand-up comedians
look down on people who do ig comedy
yeah i mean i've had stand-up comedians
tell me like you ain't it yeah yeah you
know so now you're doing standing not in
a bad way yeah and then so i said [ __ ]
it all right cool i need to earn my seat
i'm gonna earn my seat and this is even
when i already had george lopez hit me
up and be like yo
i see you keep doing your thing like
your next type of [ __ ] and then i've had
other comedians hit me up like you know
uh you know felipe esparza has been
really supportive you know what i'm
saying uh you know trollified creeper
has been really supportive
these are all guys that do stand up
um you know jerry garcia you know which
you know gave me an opportunity to do
the you know uh to host a los toxicos
tour with them so it was jingle bling
and his mat
his maga routine yeah
jesus the comedian all these guys have
been like that have been in the industry
for you know that between all of them
they got hundred plus years of
experience at stand up to tell me like
yo pursue this [ __ ] this is this is this
is where you need to be
then it was kind of like all right
because i was fighting standards i'm
gonna say how's the stand-up thing
because that's a hard thing to get into
man it's not the same obviously i mean
it's
yeah i mean it's not the same right i i
have you know uh luckily for me i come
from a rapper's lane so you're not
scared to be on stage so i ain't scared
to be on stage and command attention and
do crowd work and do all that [ __ ] right
so i've been there before now i was just
implementing hosted the tours and [ __ ]
so that's kind of like for sure yeah
yeah yeah you know i mean it's you know
from doing i mean you know like people
tell me like dawg like you should be
able to handle this you know 300 play uh
you know 300 person crowd at the laugh
factory and i try to tell them like it's
different having 17 000 people that half
of them are not even paying attention to
you yeah because there's just so much
[ __ ] going on a lot of drunk people to
300 people right in front of you and
they're like harder and they're all
harder
you know but yeah and then i come on
entertain us make me laugh
like yeah you know like it's time let's
go i pay 25 and let's get it
but not dude it's been really good um
you know uh according to my peers and
the people that have been there like yo
like you're killing it so
so it's been cool man how do you feel
like um you know because
from your perspective you have a unique
perspective coming as a rapper
shooting videos i mean you've seen a lot
of errors of like
latin hip-hop and where it's go came
from where it's going i do feel like uh
you know when i was coming up in radio
there was like the lowrider car scene
and
there was obviously you know mc magic
there was capone there was little rob
all these guys but i felt like a lot of
that music was kind of if you weren't in
that world
it was it was very um
it was like you had to
i guess it was hard to cross over right
because
it was it was the chicano rap era which
was crazy that [ __ ] was lit high power
records all that [ __ ] was going crazy
but i feel like now there's like
a lot of mexican artists who are coming
up where it's just like like that's the
thing their music is dope and they
happen to be mexican if that makes sense
yeah yeah i mean as opposed to like back
in the day i feel like you yeah yeah you
were complementalizing to a certain
genre of music right like
that was a [ __ ] that i was fighting for
10 years ago you know what i'm saying 15
years ago though you know like you know
[ __ ] that me and bass were fighting for
like where was that yeah because i feel
like bash did a good job you know being
like dude i'm just making bangers yeah
and he and he was you know i mean i mean
he was making radio [ __ ] he was making
kiss fm type music what they call it you
know whatever like [ __ ] that's like just
super pop and no matter if who it is
it's all right yeah no matter the race
it is yeah
it's on but that was a [ __ ] that you
know i was fighting for 12 years ago
where it was like
when people you said like are you a
chicano rapper he's like nah i'm not i'm
just a rapper i'm just a rapper just a
rapper and and i was doing that type of
music i wasn't necessarily banging on my
music it was just i was just doing
good street music or you know [ __ ] that
was potentially gonna be on the radio
you know what i'm saying so i wasn't
never aiming for anything like that and
then you know that goes the same with my
comedy you know i'm not doing comedy for
just chicanos either i do cater to it
you know what i'm saying but i don't
just specifically do it for them you
know i do it for whatever i think is
funny and that was the same thing with
music i wasn't doing this type of music
or that type of music i think what's
happening now with you know with all the
artists that are starting to pop that
are essentially latino dissent which
like the little pumps and you know i'm
saying like
all these dudes like that's dope man
like that's the [ __ ] that we wanted to
do 12 years ago
and you and because of the culture
changing and because of social media
it's more acceptable to just be another
race and be able to get on like that you
know i'm saying it's i don't think
little pumps the first one or you know i
mean the takashi's of the world or yeah
i mean i mean there's plenty latinos the
bad bunnies are taking over you know
what i'm saying like i mean it's it's
it's that kind of vibe i think the
industry in the world is starting to see
that the latino market
is the consumer and they buy records
facts and they follow it the fastest
growing
you know what i'm saying because we're
you know like we are the ones that
essentially buy the ticket when you're
up and we are the and we are the people
that when you're down when you're down
we go see you at the car show we go see
you at these places we are the ones that
support a lot of these rappers that were
hot 20 years ago
you know what i'm saying uh i host a lot
of the shows yeah you know what i'm
saying we the latino consumer is the one
that buys and i think you know once they
really grasp the situation you know
you know we're going to see an influx of
a lot of rappers even here from a later
gonna start to pop and not just one yeah
i mean you know obviously we got the
king little g's we got the drummer boys
artists there's a lot of dope artists
you know what i'm saying um
ruchi's mexican yeah yeah you know i
mean like so there's a lot of dope
artists that are
waiting just to bubble you know i'm
saying to get that one record that's
going to take them to the next level i
think all of them are just one record
away you know what i'm saying one record
away you know what i mean obviously
someone's like
such an error like like like peso
like there's so many dope young mexican
rappers that are like
bubbling baby young and there's just
tons of them yeah yeah there's so many
of them though there's such a crazy
movement going on right now it's still
yeah
and they're starting to see that yo we
we really support this [ __ ] we buy this
[ __ ]
and
you know i mean hopefully it gets bigger
than what it is now besides the tv show
what's like next for you man i got a
movie coming out uh it's called horchata
and oatmeal starring uh
uh jerry garcia dunno yeah dunno is
hilarious yeah do knowing me and uh and
yeah man we got some juno's [ __ ] yeah
that's a dope ass movie i can't wait for
that to come out man that's gonna be
dope and it's called horchata and oat
milk
and then i'm working on the tv show
right now called uh
uh the king of downey
uh and then that's what again with me
jerry garcia
and uh i forgot the other general i love
that county man but that's what uh
chicago uh uh chicano hollywood and then
that's what they call it right yeah
hollywood yeah yeah chicano hollywood
shout out to db lounge i love that place
i know man what else am i working on and
then i'm working on a movie it's my
first uh
my first like serious role is in this
little movie called sam's cry i play a
dad that just uh he's kind of like a
rolling stone but drug addict and
kind of wife-beater type of dude so yeah
that was crazy to play
and then i finished shooting that in uh
november are you gonna make a return to
the rap game
i had a really good conversation with
m.c magic not too long ago and what did
magic say
he says i got momentum he says why not
hey for real
you know yeah but it's like you can't do
a comedy album yeah kevin is like what
do you rap about that you know 35. you
know
do a comedy album yeah i mean i i get it
man i just you know like if anything
i'ma just rap to the ladies i said you
know i don't know i don't know if people
want to hear me like do comedy rap you
know because man you know who's going
wilder's doing really good at that like
i ain't trying to you know i ain't
trying to step on these toes man yeah
shout out what's the guys that fools
gonna while the guy with the what are
they doing little mr e little mr e man
you know like man he's he's killing it
bro you know like [ __ ] like that like
that kind of content like that's amazing
content yeah they kill it there's i mean
there's so many [ __ ] dope ages out
there dude it's just you know i'm just
trying community food's going wild
there's a lot of the food yo man yeah
i'm just trying to keep up with them dog
because they're the ones
they're [ __ ] selling out the novo
they're saying no that's crazy right
like a comedy page some comedy [ __ ] yeah
that's dope and then you know but he
want to implemented the music and yeah
that was i mean that [ __ ] is smart bro
that [ __ ] you know i can't you know you
can't knock that bro you can't knock
that like the dude made something out of
nothing
and and and and that's dope you know
like something out of a page that's
essentially free bro for sure uh what's
your ig let everybody know where they
can follow that concrete live you can
follow me at concepts
that's on all platforms at concrete live
yeah i'll pop up man go follow him yeah
appreciate you pulling up thank you yes
sir appreciate it brother